foreign
[Music]
welcome back everybody and continuing on
the critical topic of security for
Developers
our next talk is how to secure your
software supply chain and you're going
to hear this from a strategic Cloud
engineer who comes from the beautiful
German side of Lake Constance please
welcome Kristoff grotz
[Music]
so good afternoon my name is Emily
already announced me and today I would
like to speak to you about how you can
secure your software supply chain and
what's the things you might want to look
out for
so before we dive into the details I'd
like to give you a quick overview of
software supply chain security and why
it's such an important topic these days
your applications normally consist of
source code that your organizations
create and dependencies that you consume
from third parties
you probably have a build process that
takes the source codes and those
dependencies and creates packaged
software out of that these packages you
either run them in your organization or
maybe other parties consume this
packages as dependencies from you
the dependencies that you are consuming
are provided to you that might be open
source packages or that might be
commercial products from other
contributors so these contributors they
have their own software development life
cycle with their own security processes
in mind
the this as you can see constitutes a
software supply chain where you can be a
consumer of dependencies where you can
be a provider of dependencies or often
you're actually both
this may leave you vulnerable we are
consuming software from a wide range of
resources with unknown contributors and
we don't really have the transparency
into their processes
we are seeing a search in a text on this
Supply software supply chain
sonar type is has noted 650 search in
supply chain attacks year on year
and Gartner is estimating that by 2025
almost half of the world software
organization will have experienced
software supply chain attacks
at Google Cloud we are observing real
world's attacks on a wide range of
vectors in the software development
lifecycle most organizations are
focusing on source code scanning and
vulnerability scanning of the source
code
but with the vectors we observe like a
compromised build system compromise
package repositories in the action of
compromised packages those methods are
not really up to the task
so the question is what can you do to
improve your security posture as you
have already heard in the keynote we're
happy to announce a software delivery
Shield as Google's answer to that
problem
software delivery Shield is a holistic
solution it really tries to help you
from the development all the way into
the runtime it's built on Google
internal best practices like trust-based
policy systems and software delivery
Shield is a modular approach you can
take all of the components together or
you can take individual components and
integrate them with tools you are
already running as part of your software
processes
software delivery Shield supports your
SEC supports your security advices
directly in your IDE and workstations it
helps you with by managing the security
posture of your dependencies
it provides out of the box security
capabilities to your build pipelines and
it helps you with security posture
Management on your runtimes like gke and
Cloud run and with trust-based policy
system you're able to connect all of
those individual Parts together
so let's start with Cloud workstations a
secure software development life cycle
starts with where the developers
actually develop the code Cloud
workstation provides fully managed
development environments in the cloud
supporting popular Ides like vs code and
IntelliJ
and Java jetbrains IDs it's designed
with security in mind with a number of
features around that administrators can
configure private interests and private
equest they can configure VPC service
controls to prevent data accelerations
and forced image updates of the
workstations make sure that the
developers are always working on the
latest version of the development
environment
with Source protect
we are shift we shift dependency
vulnerability and license awareness left
directly into the IDE of the developer
this gives the developer much faster
feedback increasing productivity when it
comes to closing security gaps this
obviously also works with Cloud
workstations
we improved artifact registry with a
long list of features focused around
security the goal is to provide insights
faster simplify dependency government
governance sorry and reducing attack
vectors
Cloud build now supports out of the box
salsa level 3 builds this means in
addition to already providing ephemeral
and isolated built environments Cloud
build now also provides authenticated
and non-falsifiable build problems
that's very important if you need to
have auditability on your bills
and sorry one step back in the new
security insights panel I think we've
all seen that in the morning already in
the keynote you get now the salsa level
of your build you get the list the
second the software bomb of your build
you get vulnerability information and
you can see the build provenance
information we're going to take another
look at that in the demo
on the runtime side we get additional
insights and gke and Cloud run
so in gke we now have a new feature
called security posture management which
continuously scans your gke environment
and gives you recommendations on how you
can configure your workloads with hot
sex security best practices and where
you have vulnerable images and workloads
running in your environment and on cloud
run we also have the security insights
panel that you already know from cloud
built in place so that you can see the
security posture of the container you're
running
to tie everything together binary
authorization allows us to make our
security policies actionable so we can
verify with a binary authorization that
each step of our security process was
executed that we have the attestations
that this image we can trust it we can
run it on how to on our runtimes so gpe
and Cloud run
so next thing is we're going to take a
look at how this all actually connects
into the system we're going to start
with seeing how soft the delivery Shield
helps us to create secure containers
by we start with Cloud workstations
we're going to see the features there
we're going to see the insights that it
gives us then we're going to take a look
at how Cloud build helps us to build the
container we're going to take a look at
container analysis for our container
vulnerabilities then we're switching
over to the runtime we're going to check
our binary authorization
um
gives us assurance that only trusted
containers are actually running in the
runtimes and we're going to take a look
at security posture management and how
the insights that we get from there
actually then feedback right into the
developers environment to fix the
problems
so
sorry then let's move over to the demo
and of course I need to log in
you know security starts on the
developer machine
so
that's the cloud workstations overview
panel you can see I already have a
workstation we're going to take a look
into that in a second in Cloud
workstation when you want to create as a
it administrator create a new
configuration so con developer
workstations are spawned from
configurations
we get a wide range of features that we
configure on the one hand side we can
make the decisions on the on a cost
basis they're not now really security
relevant about how many workstations we
want to have pre-configured already
running to increase product developer
productivity but we can also Define
things like machine types so how big
should our developer machines are be do
we need gpus in case that we're doing AI
work on those machines
we can configure a shielded VMS secure
Boot and so on what you already know
from other parts of gcp
and we can Define the actual developer
environment so we can select uh which
image we want to run so container image
we want to run as a developer
workstation here you can see that's a
bigger list so we have Cloud code OSS we
have support for different chat prints
Ides or you can also configure a custom
image if you want to like pre-configure
the developer environment with the tools
that your organization needs and we can
of course also configure storage for
those machines
now
let's jump directly into the workstation
my workstation is already running
I can go here and I need to reload the
window
give it a second you can see it's rather
fast
so in my cloud workstation that I have
here
get rid of that
I have
Java available I have
hmm should have Maven available yes
wonderful and I'm working in a very
Standard Spring boot project
slightly older version of spring boot
I'm using a new feature from artifact
registry here that's a remote
repositories so in artifact registry we
as you have read on one of the slides
before we now support virtual and remote
repos so here I'm I have a cached remote
repository with Maven Central so that
you when you now do a maven clean
install
um
the dependencies are downloaded much
much
faster
than some version configurations and
dependencies but oh no what's that you
can see we have a few linter arrows here
this red curly lines let's hover over
that and that's now
um storage protect so here you can see
that
we have security vulnerabilities Direct
on this dependency let's check the list
out there's a remote code execution in
the spring framework version 5316 but
hey my dependencies actually spring boot
starters web
ah it gives us also dependency inside
this vulnerability insights on
transitive dependencies I mean
I guess you all have at least once in
your life called Maven install and then
it starts downloading half the internet
and maybe you're sitting there and
wondering
what am I actually downloading right now
so it's really important to understand
you might have just one dependency in
Maven and that one might not have
security vulnerabilities but who knows
what you're downloading and with those
transitive dependencies you can be
vulnerable
and what you can also see here that's
what's quite nice for each of these
dependencies if there is already a
version that is that doesn't have this
vulnerability anymore where it's fixed
it gives us also the hint okay if you
update to this minor version for example
you uh the CV is gone
so my my product owner wanted me to do a
fix so I'm just going to ignore that
real quick and
um he really wanted me to push that into
production as fast as possible so let's
just make our small fix
committee the controller
and push it into our hit report
so
Cloud build in a second hopefully should
trigger the build
and then hopefully my build goes into
production
I'm going to skip a little bit uh
in time now because it's going to take
four minutes to run the build and we
don't really have that much time
so that will be the outcome of what we
do so you can see Maven is packaging the
the project no problem with me even very
fine with Maven package we're building
the container pushing it to container to
the artifact registry but
our vulnerability signer doesn't allow
this will not sign this this image so we
don't get an attestation on this image
and the build breaks
that's obviously unfortunate and maybe
we should take a look at why why that is
so let's go to
artifact registry
and take a look at our container image
okay that's the vulnerability step with
the scan recite ah okay so critical
errors
vulnerabilities with a high impact
rating not just on the operation system
level of the container but also on the
maven dependencies which is quite
interesting for example here
probably on the next now
spring course bring security so off
there
okay but I really really want to deploy
this container I don't want to allow
what does the attestation even cause
so
obviously the good television book that
I am I prepared the command already to
deploy it let's just put our image in
here and fire away I've guessed
kubernetes will take it anyway
so let's deploy oh
that's binary authorization since the
image doesn't have the proper level of
trust finally this the signing and with
that attestation from the vulnerability
scanner
binary authorization doesn't allow us to
run the image on gke
which is great so now I actually have to
take care of all of the security
vulnerabilities
let's just pretend that I did and take a
look at the next build
where I did that ah so now wonderful the
vulnerability signer is giving us green
light it's except the snow
cves that it's complaining about so we
actually get the attestation for our
image and as part of the pipeline we're
triggering a cloud deploy to then deploy
the um the application onto the gke
Clusters
in Cloud build on build artifacts we can
now go to security insights where we get
more information about the build
artifact so on the one hand side you can
see okay there still are some critical
and high level vulnerabilities that we
as an organization made the decision to
accept the risk and we get our S1 so
here we can really see okay what's all
the dependencies that went into building
this package so we have the base layers
from topper but we also have our Java
and Maven dependencies in here and can
understand it's actually a long list of
what goes into the image
and down here the new build provenance
tab which we remember that's uh actually
a pretty cool feature because we don't
just have the s-bomb we also have how
was this image built in a way that even
after a lot of time we can still connect
this dots and there you can see okay the
image was built with Cloud build on
those hosts
um that was the entry point for the
build we can see
um the individual steps that were run on
which containers what was executed when
was it run uh what was the outcome of
the individual steps so really good
information for us
okay
now let's go over into the runtime site
as mentioned earlier so we now have a
secure container that we can actually
run on our clusters so in kubernetes we
have this new uh security posture
management feature that's basically the
dashboard that you get and what you can
see here is I have three clusters since
my application has to go through our
secure build process it doesn't have a
lot of vulnerabilities so I deployed a
few things which will raise concerns
we get two things we have to enable that
for our clusters but we get
configuration concerns so where can we
improve our kubernetes resource
definitions and we get vulnerability
concerns for the images that we have
deployed so for example here we can see
that we have a cve for expat 248 R Dash
r0 from the Alpine image and we have a
few configuration images now when you
have a lot of workloads running and you
maybe have more clusters
that's not helping you to drill it down
so that's where you go to the concern
stuff on concerns we can we have
different choices how we want how we can
analyze these concerns we can
analyze by concern type for example okay
this pod container is allowed to run as
root concern we have five workloads
affected by that maybe that's something
where we want to do a more of an
structured organizational approach to
fix it we can take a look at it on a
namespace level where we can get okay
this namespace this workload has these
vulnerabilities or on a per workload
level
for example the simple Go app has pod
container allows privilege escalation or
really useful sometimes you want to
start with the most critical things to
invest your time wisely the workday only
has so many hours so you have to decide
what you tackle first so maybe we start
actually by the critical problem the
the outdated base image
but
to for us to Circle back let's actually
take a look at from our demo app at the
Pod container allows privilege
escalation because I think it's really
useful to see we had a recommended
action
so here security posture management
really gives us directly a
recommendation how we can fix this
problem so we didn't configure any
security context in this plot deployment
so it gives us the recommendation if we
don't need it
a make it explicit and B just disable
privilege escalation so here we just go
back into our Cloud runtime Cloud
workstation sorry go into the
um our deployment
then for this container I really don't
need a privilege escalation
sorry
and just disabled and that's how
we get this continuous scanning in gke
which informs us and we're circling back
to Cloud workstations to then fix the
problem
so
let's
wrap it up
all of the features you have seen today
are available in preview stuff like
binary authorization actually for a long
time I figured
it should be at least preview
you can get started if you want to try
it out yourself with our quick start
tutorials you should check out our
software supply chain security website
to get more information on the on the
individual pieces and what you can do
and how you can use them and I recommend
that you try uh listen to the other
talks on Google Cloud next on cloud
workstations gke and tors and CI CD to
get a good picture of all the individual
parts that you're using
and that's it thank you for your
attention and enjoy Cloud next
[Applause]
[Music]